a paralympic gold winner in 2012
the only iranian woman who has ever
brought home a gold medal
nemeti is now part of the national
paralympic and olympic archery team
the 35 year old was paralyzed after a
car accident in 2003
prior to that she competed in taekwondo
competing in the olympics has been a
lifelong goal
tiro camo environment jazz i always
dreamt of the olympics to take part in
the games at some point
but i never thought that dream may come
true especially in archery
and the paralympics as well
her mental health plays a huge part in
her sport but also
in her teammates performance bessa
paksad has been with nemati for four
years
i call her the engine of the team when
she's training and is satisfied with her
work
it has a positive impact on her
teammates who try to improve and reach
her
level their expectations from themselves
raise when they see her setting another
record
nemati was the flag bearer for iran in
the opening ceremonies of the 2016
olympics
a day she says she will never forget she
has already qualified for the
paralympics in japan later this year
she is now training to compete in the
olympics as well
covet 19 has not only affected these
athletes personal lives but also their
professional ones
they couldn't train for months at the
start of the pandemic so now they are
trying to make up for lost times
they tell me even if the paralympics and
olympics are canceled later this year
they will still continue to train
because for them
it is now a way of life these women are
relatively new additions to the national
team
as they enjoy a much needed break from
the cold
a glimpse of everyday life peeks through
but zahra's focus
and determination shows no respite she
sits on a number of committees for
athletes and explains the challenges
she has faced as a woman
i think there are obstacles for women
all around the world
let alone a woman with special needs who
is wheelchair-bound and doesn't have
access to many facilities
had it not been for those challenges and
limitations zahra namati wouldn't be the
person sitting before you today
i think iranian women under all these
circumstances proved many things
and themselves to the world a country
under sanctions
a disabled female athlete and a pandemic
with no clear end in sight
all obstacles for most but here they are
viewed as hurdles to overcome
dorsa jabari al jazeera tehran